Here are the series of x, y, and z value that hold in the program as russian(20, 1) executes.
As you can see, there are two times when the value of y is added into z.
Once when x is 5--28 and 0 get added in.
Another time when x is 1--28 and 112 get added in,
and we get our correct answer of 140.
An interesting thing to note here is let's take a look at the sequence of x values.
We have one that's even, another one that's even, one that's odd,
another one that's even, one that's odd, and another one that's even.
Let's think for a second about the binary representation of the number 20.
It looks like this--1, 2, 4 plus 8, 16--4 plus 16 is 20. This is the binary representation of 20.
You can see that these zeros line up.
The 1, the 0, the 1, the 0.
Each times it's odd, we do an addition.
Essentially--actually exactly--each time there's a 1 in the binary representation
of this first value there's going to be an addition that takes place.